the founder of c-span Brian lamb is
going out like a lion lamb has some
parting shots and tough shots for
political washington the city in which
he turned a unique concept into a
mainstay of American media Fox News
media analyst and host of Fox's media
buzz Howard Kurtz on lambs early days
and final days at the helm
this is c-span Brian lamb had a
revolutionary idea 40 years ago raise
money from cable companies to televise
what Congress does miss vote the yeas
are 56 the nays are 41 the - the usual
punditry we do not offer any on-air
analysis because that's our mission no
ads no personalities no ratings but
there were some growing pains mixed
feelings about it the c-span founder
who's now stepping down made sure
ordinary citizens could weigh in tom was
in North Carolina our Republican bill in
Washington state a Democrat we created a
morning show at c-span as a result of
frankly me and others growing up having
6th Avenue in New York at ABC NBC and
CBS talked at us
never letting anybody talk back we
wanted to have the c-span network for
you somebody could call it and tell us
off lam also had a theory about the
mushrooming deficit I once thought that
Congress would waste less money if the
camera was on them at all time and I was
dead wrong a one-time radio and TV
staffer in Indiana who says he was told
to lie about Vietnam as a pentagon PR
guy Lam remains upset with political
dishonesty lying is something I really
never expected in my lifetime when I
came from Indiana to Washington DC in
1966 it was an education and I know a
lot of people would say if they hear
this a dummy this has been going on
forever I guess I was naive at 77 lamb
says he'll miss hosting a weekly show
but still loves coming to the office
give up sleeping if I could I don't even
like to sleep we all take c-span for
granted like a public utility Brian lamp
says the network was never intended to
be for everyone but for political
junkies it remains a valuable franchise
Brett how he thanks our sincere congrats
to Brian lam for an amazing career and
for bringing Washington to people around
the country